on the hill for the rockies is ryan
castellani he's an interesting young man
and he comes all the way back with a
strikeout that's very nice here's the
native of hawaii isaiah connor falefa
good pitch
i don't know if that backed up a little
bit but it stayed on the inside corner
tony sets up away
and he got him on a chain jump here's
nolan now with a great opportunity to
give the rockies a quick start against
lynn and the rangers well lanceland has
not given up a hit this year with
runners in scoring position and this is
slowly hit the short this is get a run
home
and a high throw
safe at first
sloppy defense
one-nothing rockies let's see if freige
gets that foot back down oh i think he
did there we go he is out
so that's a great review
by the rangers they get the out
and there are two gone rocky's had one
nothing top of the third inning
we see another strikeout from ryan
his fourth tonight
and a strikeout
that's five five of the first ten
well another fastball two to chew struck
him out
upstairs and now this is a running
fastball here's connor falefa
struck out looking 0-2 and a strike out
of kinder philippa arenado accounted for
the only run so far with an rbi ground
ball in the first it scored hampson
high
five
short center solar long
run and he just got there my goodness
all right
two away
that is uh pretty amazing to see
remember this is a huge outfield and he
ended up needing to
get on his horse of the full sprint with
zolac o'doron andrews coming up
this one
shout out to right and gone
first pitch swinging in solac ambushes
ryan castellani
ties the game up
with his first home run of the year
we'll have an inning nick solac just
right on time but to drive this ball
colorado or not opposite field home run
first pitch very impressive from nick
solak bottom of the sixth inning already
1-1 ball game only 57 pitches for lance
lin he's retired 15 in a row
not in front of the plate mathis not an
easy play he throws it down the right
field line
tony will end up at second base
texas
giving the rockies a nice break here to
begin the sixth inning
and mathis may ooh i thought for a
second
he may take a shot at walters at third
so hampson gets the job done go ahead
run with one out 90 feet away
and a guy who's been collecting rbi's
like m m's
of late trevor story coming up the
ribbian seven consecutive ball games
ground ball right to shorten it with
under the glove of elvis andrus thank
you and now trevor is going gonna end up
at second
and the defensive circus continues for
the rangers two to one colorado
and they've come into the game making
only seven errors this year with the 988
fielding percentage two outs nolan a
ground ball to short which did drive in
a run and pop fly to center that was
misread by solac and he ended up having
to make a diving catch coming in
there's a swing and there's a looping
drive center field solac dives he's got
it fantastic play by nick solak to steal
a run
from the rockies in an rbi from arenado
here's ruby
over two the line out to center and a
ground out to second he swings first
pitch and rips one through the right
side to base it so lock rounds third he
comes home and scores and rugnetto dora
with an rbi single in the top of the
seventh to tie the game at two his first
hit of the ball game and well there you
go brian mcmahon oh for two two one and
there's a bouncing ball weakly hit right
side ruby's got it short tossed to first
and it's a one two three inning for
lance lynn who's been a ground ball
machine tonight
seven innings in the books we're tied at
two the rangers have runners on the
corners nobody out in the eighth inning
one two
and this one instead up the middle and
that very well could be two it is
they get the double play but the rangers
take the lead dietrich comes in from
third base
and it's three to two on out nobody on
base bottom of the eighth inning and
lynn still out there you see his pitch
he strikes out hilliard here two away
his fifth strikeout of the night
it does really feel like lance lynn
reaching back for a little bit more here
swing and a miss
lancelin strikes out the side in order
in the eighth and the big fella has his
best stuff late we're gonna go to the
bottom of ninth inning and lance lynn is
gonna try to close this thing out all by
himself
in the air
out to right center
and it's tracked down by gallo
that ends it and a complete game effort
from lance lynn